thank you
no no it's not very easy but we need to
write it down
that is a good idea
is
yes
the briefing will now be at 12 40. the
briefing can be
at 12 40 now i messed up on that last
point
just hold for you eight minutes
okay
three
bacon
uh
uh
yes
on sunday
you know what uh my wife
from jared
is
okay
me
thank you
you
sure
six
okay
oh
downstairs
foreign
um
we have a two minute warning on the
press briefing the two minute warning on
the press briefing
thank you
oh
what's up buddy
[Music]
great
[Music]
uh
which is also
foreign
all right
movies
foreign
hi everyone happy friday
we tried to make this outdoors it was
not technologically possible yet one day
maybe
i have a couple of items for you at the
top uh today as a part of our help is
here tour the vice president and
education secretary cardona
are traveling to new haven connecticut
to emphasize a bold and historic
achievement of the american
rescue plan cutting child poverty in
half
in connecticut they will hold a
listening session at a boys and girls
club and visit a child
development center the american rescue
plan makes the single biggest investment
in child care since world war
ii this is hopefully going to help bring
more women back into the workforce and
address what the vice president and the
president have both called
a crisis it increases the child tax
credit from two thousand to three
thousand dollars per child and thirty
six hundred dollars for children under
the age of six
it also gives families an additional tax
credit to help out child care costs for
children
younger than thirteen uh
as you all have probably seen uh there
have been some tornadoes in
the south we are monitoring those
closely the severe weather outbreak
that's impacting of course the
southeastern
part of the united states we extend our
deepest condolences to the people in
alabama and mississippi who lost loved
ones
as a result of the severe weather
outbreak we continue to be in close
communication with state and local
officials
stand at the ready should a need for
federal assistance be made
or be required we have not received
requests at this point yet but we stand
ready to
respond to those should we receive those
requests
uh next week uh this is a we will update
the week ahead this does not have a lot
in it so uh but next week the president
will continue laying out his vision for
the future of our country
on monday tuesday and thursday he will
not be traveling he will be doing public
events at the white house we'll have
more details
of those in the coming days and on
wednesday as all of you know he will
travel to pittsburgh pennsylvania where
he will deliver a speech
laying out more details of his plan to
build the economy back better that
joshua
thanks jen uh georgia signed into law
new restrictions on voting
president biden has expressed his mole
outrage over that
there's legislation in congress but does
the administration plan to take any
executive actions
or file any lawsuits opposing these new
laws
well the administration has taken
executive actions on voting rights
and of course we will continue to review
options in that regard
i will say we expect to have a statement
from the president
on these these voting laws this voting
law i should say that passed in georgia
uh he's worried about how this
initiative uh
how this initiative sets in place
allowing states
uh to preventing states i should say to
bring water to people
standing in the la in line waiting to
vote deciding what you're going to
end vote that settings and voting at
five o'clock when working people are
just getting off of work making it more
challenging
not easier to vote deciding that there
will be no absentee
ballots under the most rigid
circumstances
like the late congressman john lewis
said there's nothing more precious than
the right to vote and speak up
the president certainly believes that
there are pieces of legislation as you
noted
but that he is watching closely that he
will be engaging with members of
congress on
including the for the people act and the
john lewis voting rights advancement
act to make it easier for all eligible
americans uh
to have to vote to have access to the
ballot box and to prevent
attacks on the sacred right to vote also
note that when he was in georgia just
two weeks ago he met with
uh stacey abrams while he was there and
he will also continue to encourage
and engage with outside leaders and
activists on steps they can take
obviously there's a range of groups and
organizations that
may take legal action that will build
will be leading in activism
uh some of that is going to be more
appropriate from outside of the white
house
and then uh two more questions uh
japan's prime minister has said
he expects to invite president biden to
attend the tokyo olympics when he comes
to the white house
there would be a big statement about the
status the pandemic worldwide
does the president plan to accept that
invite he hasn't received it yet i want
to go to the olympics does that matter
um as we've said uh we respected the
decision to delay the games
last summer we understand the careful
considerations that the japanese
government and the international olympic
committee are weighing as they prepare
for the tokyo olympics this summer
the government of japan has stressed
that public health remains the central
priority
as they plan to host the games we of
course look forward to welcoming the
prime minister
to washington soon the date has not been
formally set yet
and beyond that i don't have any
predictions on what the president's
travel will look like this summer
and then there's this ship stuck in the
suez canal has the us offered to help
or provide any kind of assistance to
resolve the problem
we are tracking the situation very
closely uh we understand that egyptian
officials are working to remove
the tanker as soon as possible and
continue traffic as part of our apple
active i should say diplomatic dialogue
with egypt we've offered u.s assistance
to egyptian authorities to help reopen
the canal we are consulting with our
egyptian partners about how we can best
support their efforts
uh so those conversations are ongoing
and hopefully we'll have more to say
about that soon
go ahead thank you we heard what the
president said yesterday about
afghanistan when do you think he will
formally postpone the may one withdrawal
date
uh well uh first let me convey the
president has not made a decision
uh at this point uh as he said yesterday
it would be tough to meet the may 1st
deadline for full
withdrawal for logistical reasons that's
consistent what with what secretary of
state
tony blinken also said in brussels
earlier this week
any uh withdrawal plan will be informed
by consultation with key leaders
within the administration and the
thinking of our partners and allies
which is of course what our secretary of
state is working on
doing uh our commitment is to bringing a
responsible end to the conflict
removing our troops from harm's way
ensuring that afghanistan can never
again
become a haven for terrorists that would
threaten the united states or any of our
allies but right now we're consulting
with our allies and partners and the
president has not yet made a decision
when do you think he will decide
jen is it is it imminent or
well obviously may 1st it's coming soon
but i don't have any timeline on it when
his decision will be made separately on
north korea
when you expect your review of that
policy to be completed
uh well we are in the final stages of
our intensive multi-stakeholder north
korea policy review
and we're of course discussing our
review with national security advisors
of south korea
and japan at our trilateral dialogue
coming up
next week and those consultations are an
important part of our review process
go ahead thanks uh jen first i want to
follow on the suez
how concerned is the u.s about the
blockage
and its effect on global commerce trade
goods getting to the u.s and other
places well we
do see some potential impacts on energy
markets uh from the role
of the suez canal as a key by
bi-directional transit route for oil and
obviously that's one of the reasons we
offered assistance from the united
states and or we are in close
consultation with the
egyptians about that we're going to
continue to monitor market conditions
and we'll respond
appropriately if necessary but it is
something we're watching closely
and then on the pandemic dr redfield the
former cdc director
said this morning that he believes that
the virus originated from
the lab at wuhan does president biden
have any
views on where the virus may have
originated or has the u.s come to a
conclusion on that yet
well as you know uh the who is examining
this and we'll be releasing a report
soon
we'll review that report once it's
available uh we continue to learn more
about the early stages of the covid19
pandemic including its origins
so we can better prepare for future
crises i know dr balenski addressed this
and i think dr fauci did as well
uh this morning and we'll look closely
at that information when it's available
oh the president's views being informed
by that who reporter or his advisors i
mean by his
health and medical advisors certainly
and so they'll review they will be of
course the people reviewing the reports
um and more data when it becomes
available and then last one on
the forced labor in xinjiang and china
some companies have come under pressure
from the chinese government
and some retailers have actually dropped
pledges not to use
products made with forced labor from
that region so
what is the us doing to stop or deter
china from making those kind of threats
against companies that have resulted in
this problem
well we certainly have been watching
this issue closely as you all know and
we've taken our own
uh strong actions in order to prevent
china from profiting off of its horrific
human rights abuses in xinjiang
and to stop imports of products made
with forced labor in china
american consumers and consumers
everywhere deserves to know that their
goods are that the goods they are buying
are not made with forced labor and many
companies are standing up for consumers
rights
the international community in our view
should oppose china's weaponizing of
private companies dependence on its
markets to stifle free expression
and inhibit ethical business practices
so it is something we are
watching closely we of course taken our
own action i would expect that
uh state and commerce will have more to
say on this later today just one quick
follow-up though it's because it seems
like you've been
having this message out there for the
first couple months of this
administration but it's
china only seems more emboldened to
threaten these companies so what more
can be done from the white house to try
to deter them from making these threats
well we can work with our international
partners
uh obviously as i conveyed on how we're
going to
push back on china's efforts to
weaponize uh private companies and we
can convey
publicly as we are now and of course
engage with private sector entities
about these efforts but
a lot of that action would happen from
commerce and in some cases the state
department and again i expect they'll
have more specifics to say later today
on this
um go ahead a few questions on the who
investigation that's coming out jake
sullivan the national security advisor
said
a few months ago that they had deep
concerns about the way that
investigation was being conducted did
they still have
those deep concerns uh in part because
there was a lack of transparency and
there was a lack of we weren't ensured
that we
would have access to the data available
so there was a delay they actually
delayed the release of that report which
we were encouraged by
we'll have to take a look at it and make
sure we have access to the underlying
information
so what happens if the report comes out
and president fiden is not satisfied
with it not satisfied with the report
well we've also we've also called for an
international
um investigation and look into uh what's
what's happened
and the origin not just the origin i
should say the uh lack of transparency
from the chinese we have reinstituted or
re-engaged
with uh through staffing of our
of our team on the ground in beijing so
we'll see what the report says where we
have concerns we'll look at the
underlying data if we have access to
that and then we'll have to make a
determination through an interagency
process on what's next
and just to get some clarity on
yesterday are we should we still be
expecting executive orders from the
president
on gun measures yes definitely or what's
what do you
like a month from now what do you think
the time for i can't give you an exact
time frame in part because they have to
go through a review process which is
something that
uh we do from here uh you know i will
note that um
you know when we when the president was
the vice president in the obama biden
administration
he helped put in place 23 executive
actions to combat gun violence
it's one of the levers that we can use
that any federal government any
president can use to
help address the prevalence of gun
violence and
address community safety around the
country at the same time
he continues to believe that there is an
opportunity to
engage with congress there are two
background bill
background check bills that um are have
been proposed have been introduced have
been working their way through
uh there have also been legislation
introduced to abandon assault weapon
ban assault weapons but he also believes
that there is an opportunity and and
sometimes that the
best path forward is working through
states and there has been
progress made we've seen over the last
several years 20 states now have
extended
background checks 19 states have read
flag laws seven states now have assault
weapons bans
we know they work and so we have to
address this epidemic address the threat
of gun
violence uh across many avenues and he
will
he's committed to doing that okay and
then also does he have a reaction to the
georgia state representative who was
arrested overnight
when knocking on the georgia governor's
door as he was signing that
election law i think anyone who
saw that video uh would have been uh
deeply concerned uh by uh the actions
that were taken
uh by law enforcement to arrest her when
she simply by the video that was
provided uh
seemed to be knocking on the door to uh
to see if she could uh
watch a bill being signed into law the
larger can
the largest concern here obviously um
beyond her
uh being treated in the manner she was
which is of course a great concern
is the law that was put into place which
again the president will will have a
statement from the president
i expect later this afternoon on it
should not be harder it should be easier
to vote uh we should not put limitations
in place people should be able to
vote from home they should be able to
use absentee ballots uh there should be
a range of
uh restrictions that are undone not put
back in place and so that's a great
concern one he certainly shares uh with
the
uh with the elected official who was
arrested does he plan to reach out to
her
i don't have any calls to preview for
you if he does i will certainly
uh provide an update to all of you good
thank jen
a couple follow-ups on yesterday the
president said he thinks the filibuster
is a legacy of the jim crow era
did he think that it was a legacy of the
jim crow era in 2005 when he defended
the filibuster and said offering senate
rules to help one political fight or
another could become standard
operating procedure which in my view
would be disastrous
well peter one of the things he talked
about yesterday was the fact that
between 1917 and 1971 the filibuster was
used about 58 times last year
last year alone it was used five times
that many
it is not being used for the intended
purpose it is being abused
and yes there are scenarios as it
relates to voting rights where it is
it is oppressing it is is is allowing
for
systematic racism in the country so
that's the concern he was expressing and
following that there are some concerns
on the right that if you get rid of the
filibuster it effectively means one
party rule so is that what the president
was getting at
when he was asked about 2024 and he said
i have no idea if there will be a
republican party
well that certainly wasn't what he was
getting at given as part of his answer
he conveyed that
his objective and his hope is to work
with republicans
he wants to get work done for the
american people he wants to put in place
solutions
put people back to work get the pandemic
under control make voting easier and
more accessible
and it's really on republicans in
congress to decide if they're going to
be part of the solution if they're
going to be a part of obstruction so
he's leaving it up to them to make the
decision on what role they want to play
in history
on the border the president said
yesterday the vast majority of the
overwhelming majority of people coming
to the border and crossing are being
sent back but
only 13 of the 13 000 families that
tried to cross
last week were sent back according to
axios so where do we get a majority out
of 13
the vast majority of adults are being
sent back okay so the family units
87 of them are being taken into the
united states to
either be resettled or awake
uh await their hearings i'm just curious
87
in the country of the family units is
not
a majority consent that a majority of
adults which every adult is not a part
of a family union
as i'm sure you're fully tracking um and
tens of thousands of people are coming
to our border
we know that um and so the majority of
adults are being turned away
uh our policy remains the same we are
implementing section 42.
as the president touched on and i
touched on a little bit earlier this
week
uh we there are capacity issues in
mexico which we are in discussions with
them about addressing
and they are not uh in a position to
accept and take the families that they
have in the past so that's part of the
diplomatic discussions that we're having
okay just one more about yesterday uh
we noticed starting at the end of the
campaign
and then into the transition and here at
the white house anytime that the
president has
an event where he's given a list of
reporters to call on
fox is the only member of the five
network
tv pool that has never been
on the list in front of the president
and i'm just curious but that is
official administration policy we're
here having a conversation aren't we
and do i take questions from you every
time you come to the briefing room
yes but has the president taken
questions from you since you came in
since you he came into office
unfortunately yes or no only when i have
shouted after he goes through his whole
list and the president has been very
generous with his time with fox i'm just
curious about this
list that he has given so the only
member of the five network pool never
on it dating back to when he resumed
in-person events in wilmington during
the
end of the campaign well i would say
that i'm always happy to have this
conversation with you even about your
awesome socks you're having on today you
we're in today
and have a conversation with you even
when we disagree the president's taking
your questions
and i'm looking forward to doing fox
news sunday this sunday for the third
time
in the last few months i think we got to
move on because we got limited time go
ahead kristen
jenn thank you the president talked
about the importance of
kids going back to the classrooms in
many schools all across the country
they are not going back to the
classrooms and there aren't many plans
to do so because teachers unions say
that they want their teachers to be
vaccinated first you know the cbc says
that's not required how are you going to
deal with that and
are there any discussions about saying
to teachers unions you have to go back
to the classrooms
well first actually 76 of schools are
do have teaching uh do have kids in the
classroom for part of the week and about
46 percent
uh are back five days a week and we
expect that to continue to increase over
time
he wants the majority right but by day
100 and we're on track to meet that
objective
uh i will say that we took a step in
this administration to prioritize
teachers
uh through our pharmacy program we that
program is working it's effective
teachers can go they are prioritized
at pharmacies it's something we had the
power to take and implement
even without even and we feel it's very
much in line with the cdc guidelines
because
it is one of the mitigation steps and
it's a step we had the power
to take and put into place we actually
don't see an issue
uh coming up with um with uh schools not
reopening they are reopening
more reopening every single week and uh
we certainly feel we're on track to meet
our goal and
when you look at some of the polling as
it relates to the vaccinations
there's still about 30 of adults say
they don't plan
to get one how do you get things back to
normal
with those types of figures and when
specifically do you
plan to move forward with the vaccine
campaign to try to
improve it it's launching kristin it's
happening uh we we are
launching a public campaign there are
some details that have been out
um and reported um uh i believe in the
wall street
journal we'll get all that information
out to all of you uh i will say that uh
what we have
um learned from our own data is that
part of our investment and focus
needs to be in trusted voices and
trusted partners we've seen
some improvement in confidence uh
among a range of communities in the
efficacy of the
of the vaccine that that's good news
right uh what we have seen
concern about and what we still have
concern about is
access and that is the big issue because
now when we start to
um get to uh get to the point where we
are trying to reach uh
more and more and more communities of
course vaccinate adults
americans in this country a lot of
people can't take a day off to go
get a vaccine they don't have a
flexibility to be
in the slot available they maybe can't
drive
three miles to their local pharmacy so
our big investment right now
is in access that means increasing
investments in mobile units
in community health centers in mass
vaccination sites
but it also means in terms of the public
campaign
investing in trusted voices and
empowering local groups and
organizations
to have the funding the information and
the assistance they need
just to follow up with my question with
the president yesterday
i asked him about transparency and
access for journalists into some of the
facilities at the border
the president said i will commit when my
plan is underway
to have access it sounded to a lot of
people like he was saying i will let
more cameras in
once i'm satisfied with the conditions
how is that consistent
that's not actually what he meant i'll
first say we did allow access including
an nbc camera exclusively into the
shelter facility on wednesday
and we're committed to increasing access
and doing additional pools
uh making it available these facilities
including the border patrol facilities
as well
as the shelters what he was conveying is
right now his focus
is on moving these kids uh out of these
border patrol facilities
right and making sure it's done in a way
that keeps them safe and keeps everyone
safe
that does not imply that we are not
going to allow access
until that is done it implies that is
his first focus
so um i thanks for asking the question
that was his and
that was his intention time frame for
when
and noted that nbc did go in as pool do
you have a time frame
for when the next round of cameras might
be allowed in oh we're working on it
hopefully
soon uh and it's something we're
certainly committed to and we're just
working with dhs and hhs and when we can
make it possible
oh go ahead so obviously they're on guns
obviously there's lots of pieces of
legislation the president is advocating
for but when he spoke yesterday about
priorities
some gun control groups felt frustrated
they felt like he was saying
gun control is not a priority compared
to infrastructure compared to buildback
better
what's your response to to groups who
took that message away from the
president's comments yesterday
well first the president understands
their frustration and he understands it
as one of the few people
in government who ever beat the nra
twice by leading the fight to pass the
brady bill and the assault weapons ban
he understands as a person who led the
effort at president obama's request to
strengthen gun measures
after sandy hook and when that was voted
down helped put in place 23 executive
actions to combat
gun violence you'll see more executive
action as josh and others were asking
about and that review is underway
and more efforts by him and the
administration to move forward in the
weeks ahead whether that is
on legislation supporting efforts that
are happening in states which we've seen
is very effective and impactful and
largely due to the advocacy and activism
of a lot of these
uh groups uh but you know we would say
that um
the frustration should be vented at the
members of the house and senate who
voted against the measures the president
supports and
we'd certainly support their advocacy in
that regard and on the border
secretary has put out a statement saying
this is the highest pace of border
crossings
in 20 years yesterday president zidane
made it seem
like this is not too unusual compared to
other previous years that
in terms of the number of people trying
to cross the border it's about average
those don't seem to swear how does the
administration view this in terms of
whether this press netted or whether
this is an increase well the president
was making the point that we have seen
increases
at the border in 2014 when he was the
vice president
2018 and 2019 and he conveyed that over
the last six months of the
uh trump administration there was an
increase of about 31
we've seen an increase of about 29 over
the last
several months since he took office so
the point is we've dealt with this
before
uh it is often seasonal uh it is often
cyclical
and he just wanted to convey that in his
effort to
to communicate and be provide
educational information to the public
but that doesn't change the fact that he
is addressing this
by putting forward every resource at our
disposal in the administration
just in this past week we've taken steps
to bring a number of new facilities
online
from fort bliss where there are 5 000
beds to lachlan air force base where
there are 350 beds
san diego convention center 1400 beds
these three sites alone
provide at peak capacity an additional
sixty six thousand seven hundred and
fifty beds one of our biggest issues as
we've talked about before
is uh moving these kids out of the
border patrol facilities into the
shelters
uh and we need to have places that are
safe that have educational resources
health resources mental health resources
legal resources
this is a step toward doing that the
other piece where he has been very
focused as we all have been
is on expediting processing at the
border and earlier this week the office
of refugee resettlement
also instituted a revised policy for
certain children who have a parent or
legal guardian in the united states
this will add more capacity and more
swiftly unite kids with relatives and
sponsors so of course there should be a
difference if it's a
direct family member a mother or father
um and an
a different kind of adult right so there
are steps to that we are taking to try
to expedite
even the processing so our focus is on
actions and solutions
we certainly know this is a challenge
it's something he has briefed on
regularly um and has
is pushing his team to take more rapid
action go ahead peter thank you jeff
uh the president has said he wants
bipartisan support
for infrastructure packages well is that
possible
when republicans are pretty adamant they
don't want tax increases
in other words how can we achieve
bipartisan support for infrastructure
if republicans are are drawing the line
a hard line on tax tactics
well first i would say peter that i
don't think most republicans think that
the united states one of the wealthiest
countries in the world should be 13th in
the world as it relates to
infrastructure
you know roads that are broken down
infrastructure that isn't working
a lack of access to broadband that's not
a democratic issue
and the president is going to continue
to make that case
now we don't know what the votes will be
we haven't proposed a package yet
uh and certainly what it will be tied to
and the pay fors will be a part of that
discussion
but he certainly believes there's been a
history of support for
investing in infrastructure uh he has
had bipartisan meetings in the white
house he's worked with democrats and
republicans on getting
legislation uh you know getting steps
taken in the past
uh and he's he's hopeful that uh that
that there's an agreement on that moving
forward go ahead anita
thanks um six former commissioners
fda commissioners have called on the
president to go ahead and
nominate an fda commissioner uh you
probably saw this week
that the second in command there is has
announced that she's leaving
i'm wondering what when the president
plans to appoint someone or nominate
someone in the fda
but more broadly i wondered if you could
talk a little bit about
why the president is behind presidents
obama and trump on appointing
both at the fda and a variety of other
vacancies including
the deputy secretary at dhs and the
listener general
well i'll also point out that the
president
is also the first president to have all
15 cabinet nominees confirmed on this
timeline and without a single one
dropping out if we're just making
comparisons between administrations
he certainly wants to have an fda
commissioner in place he wants it to be
the right person and uh you know there
sometimes is a journey on personnel and
determining
who the right person is for the job
who's willing to do the job who's
available to do the job and
it's a priority but i don't have a pre
an update for you on on when
he will nominate in general just on some
of these other positions
i take your point about the cabinet i'm
asking about some others so
what was your question again more
broadly why he's behind on some of these
other positions that are not the actual
cabinet that you've referred to
well i think it's a little bit of apples
and oranges we obviously have made a
great deal of progress
on again the people who are running and
leading these agencies more than any
administration since the reagan
administration we feel
very good about that we've also walked
into a white uh presidency where he is
dealing with a pandemic that is still
killing 1 000 people a day
10 million people out of work racial
injustice across the country a climate
crisis
so he's got a few things on his plate
but he is committed to personnel
moving things forward and certainly
wants to have a full team across
agencies and then if i could just follow
up on something you mentioned
title 42 which closes the border to
non-essential travel
um several before president biden was
president several lawmakers including
then senator harris
now vice president obviously called it
unconstitute an
unconstitutional executive power grab
that had no known precedent or
clear legal rationale why is that still
something that is that he has not
rescinded what is he reviewing that what
is the situation there he clearly
doesn't
agree with the vice president on that
it's in place for public health reasons
giving we're in the midst of a pandemic
um that's why it's in place i think
we're gonna have to move on go ahead
uh a couple of questions jen um
since january the number of americans
who have been tested for colic
has dropped off dramatically as more
people are getting vaccinated
this is a real concern for public health
officials who think that testing is
you know cornerstone to keeping the
pandemic in check so
what is the administration's plan is to
make sure that those testing numbers
don't fall off further
that's where people get vaccinated
you're absolutely right and testing is a
key part of returning to normalcy
whether it's schools or workplaces or
businesses especially as we still have
a majority of the population that still
needs to be vaccinated although we're
working to expedite that
there is funding in the american rescue
plan there is funding
to also allow for that or institute or
give funding i should say
to schools to also uh make that
available there so it's something that
we'll continue to communicate about to
governors to
school leaders to businesses about the
importance of testing and we have
resources now that have been
passed in the american rescue plan to
help alleviate some of the cost
and one more the nfl has announced that
it is not going to require
players coaches staff members to get the
copic vaccine
if they want to play practice etc is
that a mistake then should this vaccine
be required for athletes
well i i would certainly i don't know
that we're making nfl policy from here
but it is certainly recommended
by public health officials uh by uh
officials from our federal government
because it's how
we can keep people safe and healthy
whether it's our family members
or our friends or people in the stands
who are attending these games so
certainly we would advise any entity
to follow public health guidelines to
recommend
that their players that members of the
nfl
follow those public health guidelines
whether it's mask wearing social
distancing
washing hands and certainly getting the
vaccine when they have access
go ahead uh so a question again about
voting rights uh the president's express
support for hr1
yeah he's gonna put out a statement
later today what else does he have
planned
as far as travel or working with
senators to push the legislation forward
what other specifics can you share about
his use of bullet pull but to push that
forward
one more question on behalf of okay no
problem um first as the president
conveyed yesterday
he feels that voting rights
are pushing back on voting rights making
it harder
to vote is un-american
it is something that should not be a
part of society in any regard even many
republicans across the country oppose
the efforts that have been undertaken
in states like georgia to make it more
difficult he will certainly continue to
vocalize that
as he did quite passionately yesterday
he met with stacey abrams when he was in
georgia
and he will of course use
his role as president to engage with and
work with members of congress and
leaders to help to move these pieces of
legislation forward into the senate okay
and the other question is uh
when children arrive at the border
children arrive
uh and they're not with their biological
parents or with uncles grandparents
they are sometimes separated from them
uh and they become another
company admirer at that point does the
administration look at changing that
policy
to let don ever stay together when
they're not a biological parent
well i think that um there are steps
that are taken to ensure because there
has been a history of child trafficking
right
um and we uh want to prevent that from
being risk
that is children are uh that is posed to
children um
i'm not aware of any uh consideration of
changes i'm happy to check and see if
there's anything underway it would
decrease the number of unaccompanied
minors if they can stay with
an anthropology that certainly is true
but i think you have to we have to
ensure that individuals are vetted
that they are who they say they are and
there have unfortunately been cases in
the past where that has not been the
scenario so we are mindful of that as
well
good um i have a question about the
iowa second international district race
four republican senators in a letter to
corporations are calling the battle
for the tip for democrats to make back
the seat an
unacceptable attempt to undermine the
legitimate democratic process does the
president agree with their assessment
i believe the that the the process that
is outlined uh by the house of
representatives is what's being
followed here to ensure every vote is
counted um so no he wouldn't agree with
that
and i just need one more question uh
will the white house comply with the
white white house democrats request for
documents from the last six weeks of the
trump administration
as part of their investigation into what
happened on january 6.
those a lot of those documents would be
in the national archives i believe so
i'm not sure it would be white house
documents but
if they're white house documents i can
certainly ask our lawyers but i think
most of them would be in the national
archives from the past administration go
ahead
thank you jen has the president been
briefed or seen the images of migrants
that have passed away at the border in
the past couple of days including a
nine-year-old girl
and does he have any response to that
well
i would say this is um uh he is
regularly briefed by his immigration
team
and kept abreast of all developments at
the border um
i would say that those images are a
reminder of how
dangerous this journey is and why this
is not the time to come
and it's just is a reminder of how
important it is that
we work together this is not a partisan
issue this is an issue where we're
talking about people's lives
children's lives and we're focused on
working with anyone who wants to be part
of a solution to
address the challenges we're facing and
when you and the president yesterday
talk about negotiating with mexico what
is mexico asking for
to take the migrants back i don't think
we're going to get into its
private negotiations i will just say
that it's not a question of
if uh but when uh when uh we
uh work work through with uh the mexican
government uh
being able to have the capacity to
take some of these families back um part
of the discussion
of course when when ambassador jacobson
and others were in the region was
on exactly these issues but it was just
the first trip as we
announced just a couple of days ago the
vice president will be playing an
important role here
uh there we have just announced an envoy
and these discussions will be ongoing we
didn't expect this first trip to be
conclusive
and as you make now the infrastructure
package your next priority where does
immigration reform
fall on the list of priorities for this
white house any white house including
ours
has to walk into gum at the same time
move forward on a range of priorities a
range of crises facing the country
so we will continue to work with members
of congress work with outside groups uh
continue to advocate for moving
long overdue immigration reform forward
go ahead
yesterday the president mentioned
inviting an alliance of democracies
uh before too long yeah can you define
when
before too long might be and whether it
would be
uh to the white house bless you thank
you
uh whether they would come to the white
house and how many countries
does he envision inviting that's a great
question there's not he's something he
talked about broadly on the campaign
trail
i don't have any additional details at
this point in time i expect we'll have
some more on our climate summit soon
which is would be the
the next summit type of international
engagement
uh but i don't have anything to preview
for you on that particular
event uh prime minister
suga's visit to washington was announced
like two weeks ago by the japanese
government
and i wondered what is why is there a
hold up in announcing
the date oh it's not it's not it's we're
working out the final date and logistics
we're looking forward to welcoming
the prime minister here um but i
wouldn't read anything into it about
that
thanks everyone happy friday
you